anyways but ok so just to remind you
what we were doing so we defined for
every cold in the hemming space we
define this parameter namely these
decoding radius maximum relative radius
such that for every ball of saturate
this radius does not contain more than L
points ok and so after some pain we
learned yesterday that a oh yeah of
course and what you're interested in so
the theorem that we're trying to prove
is a tau L star of rate that were any
code of radar this tau L star is upper
bounded by some function g one of Delta
L P one of our where this is the linear
programming bound so now the LP one of
our is one half minus root better one
minus beta and g one of new i'll define
it in a second sorry I mean I ok I can
define it right now but it's the
following strange object ok so and these
guys are my ID Bernoulli you ok so the
expectation of ok so this is expectation
of the average radius of the following l
plus 1 points the first so I'll I didn't
define what the average radius is but
it's a certain function so and the
points are this is all one dimension so
this is this points are zero and and L
Bernoulli Heidi vectors and expectation
was over them sorry not vectors again 01
values so in particular for example for
l equals 3g one of a offices for only
four odd l great
no right and for l equals 3g 1 over nu i
mean it's always a polynomial that's
something like this just explicit okay
so what's the average radius so the
average radius offer so what's the usual
radius the usual radius of any set is
the minimum over all possible centers
basically it's the a choice of radius
right so it's the smallest circumscribed
sphere asos the minimum over Y points on
the real line it's one-dimensional yes
the radius is the distance between to a
no but this is hemming space so hey its
majority yes yes I do then I don't
understand setting be one up to be lr
number one numbers right and you
consider the Hamming distance ok yeah
you can consider the cleaning business
ok I don't understand osea say okay so
you see right right so I'll write it so
a so when you when you do the radius of
circumscribes here right it's like k
you're saying if i have two points for
example 0 & 1 i can put the center here
but no this is forbidden because this
point is not in my space I'm sorry okay
doesn't write the definitional you'll
see so it's so this is the definition of
the a of the radius of a set right
s is a subset of F 2 F 2 to the N and
the average radius or the moment of
inertia is minimum over why I mean all
these guys are in f2 and that's
important here you just compute the
average distance
why let you define the radius of a set
and write what appears there is is that
I said it looks to me like a vector ah
yeah good point this is a bad notation
okay right at somewhat it's a set with
multiplicities the bees are let's say 10
times and one appears l minus 10 times
and then if you just fit yes yes right
exactly so yeah so this is abuse of
notation I don't know how do you do not
order it set is there okay okay so now
I'll just keep writing this notice that
ok
right so okay so a right so the way the
bound looks oh actually in this in terms
of this notation the plot can radius is
what so this is the this is the general
trade off our versus towel right to the
bouncer like this and this point tau L
star at zero is something like expected
average radius of b1 up to be l plus 1 I
think and these are Bernoulli one-half
so this is just what Bruno's keep rude
so a hopefully I'll get to the point
where you will see why a okay right
right but this is just the usual Plotkin
point in the in the full original
problem okay so what we did yesterday
learned that from cali lineal there
exists size zero and okay it's very
important that disk size zero is between
one half root beta 1 minus beta beta is
found from solving for a rate sorry for
solving this equation
with what property okay so there is a
size zero and cold word in the code such
that a C+ sphere of radius sigh 0n a
intersected with the code contains
greater than 2 to the N are prime old
words metric way so we started with some
unknown code and collide lineal give us
a sum sum called some point in the cold
and the sphere such that there are
exponentially many code words on that
sphere this is the first step in my
reduction right so then I forget about
everything else and i'm just going to
compute the coverage radius at least
decoding radius of this subset this code
point plus it is exponentially many a
code words on onus on the sphere ok
let's call this guy this intersection
right this is c prime ok so i think it's
a gentle breath actually yeah i think
it's the excellently wrote 1 minus bit h
okay so so for example if just sort of
we're going to be mostly interested in
this regime and so when the rate is
epsilon then beta is root apps on and
sighs at this point this point is going
to be one half minus a root apps say
that's important so this is sort of the
parameters and size zero and actually we
will see that okay later we need to
optimize which because we don't know
where this fear is right we only have
upper and lower bound sorry we have
upper bound so we need to take the worst
bound and the worst bound will always be
on the boundary right so so just to
think about parameters this is the
interesting case right so my sphere is
almost of the full radius and minus root
the rate okay so so then the next step
and I hope to talk a little bit about
today is to solve this subproblem right
so now we are solving some problem even
s0n which is a hemisphere right
a question ok so then pack a maximum
number of points
such that the following so it usually we
code for the minimum distance or for the
least decoding radius right so here we
called for some absolutely useless
parameter which I think never appeared
anywhere but so this is the metric of
interest for us for the code it stay a
maximum Bo maximum radius such that ball
intersected with C has less than L minus
1 points and this ball in addition for
all balls which intersect which contains
zero so it's like you want to pack
points such that you know there you
cannot include L of them in any ball
which also includes a zero you want to
minimize this ok so it's obvious that
this radius can never a so this tau L is
always greater than one-half X I 0 right
just because if you want to include any
point here and 0 your radius has to be
half of this right and on the other hand
it's obvious that this tau L is looks
smaller than size zero right because if
you just put the center of the ball here
you include everything ok so then we
know two things about this trade-off
already right so if you consider the so
the maximum rate you can have as H of
size zero right the size of the sphere
and here we have these two points and
the question is okay so where does this
rate hit zero right so what's this point
and this is basically the main work that
so this reduction is the same as a
shipment bargain listen so the main work
was to establish this oh actually yes
why yes they I forgot to mention what's
the term I mean when you think about it
there are many points that you can
improve in this proof in my opinion but
my main motivation was to show zero
slope why because a one of the abl
authors which showed zero slope for
least two they told me i am i'm not
going to say who but they told me that
they believe hundred percent that linear
programming methods are unable to show
you
slope for any loose size gray turn to
why because basically linear programming
methods are inherently point pairwise
and you need to consider three pies and
quadruple I statistics to say anything
meaningful about lisa is greater than
two so that's so once I showed this zero
slope I mean I just wanted to show an
example that you know it's actually
possible a ok so right and okay so yeah
so the main proposition is the following
rainy cold with huge size how l0 of C so
this weird metric packing metric is
always upper bounded by g1 oxide zero so
II so how we're going to prove this okay
so for that let's first a let me first
do the following simple computation so
the proof as sort of warm up step 1
let's consider the following different
metric of the cold i will call tau L bar
which is the average radius right so
this is going to be expectation of
radius 0 C 1 up to CL
those guys are taking uniformly see
okay so I mean this is a different
metric right of course the average a the
average such radius is always a lower
bound right tau L 0 she is always
greater than tau l bar u OC but so there
is no upper bound like this which I can
stay but let's just still do it let's
show that a if this is my figure of
Merit then this is the right plotkin
point okay so how are we going to do it
so for that I just need to know okay so
so when you compute the radius right so
suppose I give you some number of
vectors in high-dimensional having space
so on so the important thing is that
radius the average radius can be
computed on a per column basis why
because the only thing you care about is
really so basically the center is always
the majority vote right so the center of
moment of inertia is always majority
vote per column right so you can see
there each column and compute the
majority vote right so okay so then a
again this this here you have basically
two averaging right the averaging of a
selection of a point so you can
interchange these two averages and so so
this quantity is basically the following
so if you write down the code as 1 plus
2 to the N are 2 to the N our matrix
right off and its 1 2 to the N here so
if you write this matrix right so a and
you look so when you compute this
expectation of this radius what you
should do is you should select a random
subset of size L write a random of
science
l right add 0 here and then compute the
majority vote for this random subset
compute majority vote and a an average
over all such selections right so
basically what I'm saying is that it's
very easy to just verify that this
expectation is always equal to the
following thing so just inequality just
exactly equal to sum over i from 1 to N
of this g 1 oh yeah and of course so
let's define the density of one's here
to be lambda i right so then when you
select a random subset of size l right
basically because L is fixed and this
number is growing what you get the
statistics is exactly i ad Bernoulli
right for this beats this is some kind
of like selection with replacement
without replacement right so it's ok so
what you get is this function G one
which is exactly what we need right the
average radius in one dimensional case
and lambda i's is the density of ones in
I've call once in I've column
this is just a quote there is no
cheating here okay then you actually
absorbed it luckily these g1 functions
are concave so then this is always upper
bounded by n times G 1 sum of lambda i's
normalize by n okay and 0 vector which
which we put as an anchor for our radius
computation right now just by seeing
that ok this cold sea lies every every
row contains exactly size 0 times n1
right this is just sort of averaging in
two different ways right so this is
exactly size zero right so this is a
okay so a right so you can see that the
the rate the average radius of arbitrary
code is always upper bounded by what
what I claimed here ok now you can
actually indeed what you if you just do
a random selection of 22 then are a
points uniformly in the sphere you can
easily see that the average of that
random selection will actually hit this
very easily and basically what I'm
saying is that this this this estimate
is tight i mean you need to do some
exploitation run apply this bound ok so
okay so this is achievable now the
question is how do we go so we now know
that this a sort of we have an upper
bound on a lower bound right so far it's
completely useless think so how do you
guarantee how to now guarantee
0of see is also less than g one
okay so okay so so far let's just
understand that this was a lamb alright
simple computation that the only thing
we use is that this this number of Cold
War's grows to infinity right that's the
only approximation we used here to
replace this selection with replacement
to something without replacement and
okay so okay so now I need to tell you
howhow actually blue mosque approved
this estimate because it's so far I'm
just following his strategy he did
exactly the same thing and he was able
to show a that indeed average radius and
the maximum radius can be interchanged
let me quote his result
Oscar showed
every cold or ever large cold there
exists a sub code which is much smaller
than C but still basically when I write
this this means as as the size of this
code goes to infinity the size of his
sub code also goes to infinity with the
astonishing property that the average
radius is equal well approximately equal
as n goes to infinity approximately
equal to the maximum radius ok so then I
knew this result right so when I showed
that I mean oh yes sorry the sea prime
right so basically every code contains
the what he called the symmetric
sub-code namely the guy for whom average
radius and maximum radius are exactly
the same thing so now the question is ok
I knew this result and this all I mean
took me maybe including kalai lineal
maybe I don't know one day and at this
point I thought ok so this is very
simple computation you know check it so
I have ok now I just need to prove that
the same thing holds for tau L 0 for
this weird anchored average radius right
but actually it's it's not true for 40
zero
zero vs towel 0r so here is a very
simple counterexample so let's remember
this is our anchor right so 0 is always
there and so we put all the points here
right and think of ELQ huge something
like 10 million right so--okay so you
have 0 and then lots of notes of points
here so then what's the average radius
if L is gigantic right and this remember
we are averaging and then the
contribution of 0 as if it doesn't exist
right so then tau L is approximately
zero but the maximum radius is always at
least half right so a so there's
absolutely no hope improving such a
result so here I need to admit to you
that I've been buying everywhere here
actually this is not true and what is
true is that i need to replace this
estimate by something else so it's about
five minutes ok so i think and again I
my time planning is very bad because I
hope to so yeah so okay so what I could
prove it was the following so
every see for every code on the sphere
there exists c prime subset of C and C
prime while goes to infinity as C goes
to infinity with what property well with
the property that tau L 0 of C prime is
approximately equal to not to the
average we know it cannot be true right
but it's equal to the following
interesting thing its maximum over j
going from 0 to l of what of something
which is very close to the average
radius in spirit
first add 0 j times then you put average
over over your L code words selected at
random right again the subset of L code
words selected uniformly at random right
only c prime L right ok so so you can
see that basically in this I what I do
here is a for each j right i mean as i
add more and more zeros here I improve
the contribution of 0 right and that's
why this counter examples basically
disappears because when for example you
add many many j's here the contribution
of j becomes at least as much as the
collective contribution of all those
guys ok so the proof is yeah I don't
have time but mmm it's not terribly
different from do not see I mean I was
surprised that I could do something like
this there's one extra trick I needed to
use this and I think yeah so one thing I
noticed is that by using minimax theorem
you can prove the following a general
property of the radios that this radius
is approximately equal it was just
exactly month it's x equal to max /
distribution P of of radius R
raised bar of what of c1 up to CL but
when you compute the radius you have
waited a weighted contributions with
weights p 1 up to PL so p is the
distribution this is not trivial and
this is action not true the way I stated
that but plus minus 2 to the L so the
reason you never probably seen such a
thing is because when people compute
radius they are very rarely interested
in my regime right where my regime is
the dimension of my space is huge and
the list is fixed right so that's why
such approximation basically this is
mini marks theorem here and that's what
allows me to a you know carry over
expectations and so on so this is this
is what connects radius to expect the
radius plus there is rum see a similar
ization happening okay so right so so
this basically so this tells me tells me
that what I need to replace here is I
need to put maximum over J of GJ where
gigi is exactly what i defined as
expected radius and dimension one but
with Jay zeros added a and but actually
so when size 0 is greater than one half
minus Delta so when it's very close to
one half and remember that's the regime
of interest in low rate right it turns
out that the maximum is always achieved
maximum is achieved at Jacobs one when L
is odd hold and j 0 when l is even
okay so this is the math explanation why
my proof doesn't work for even because
GGA g0 actually looks like this and it
achieves so it hits one half with zero
slope but g one has a constant slope
here at one-half so a that's why when
you plug it plug this thing in here so
if or even L you get you have to square
this epsilon so you get the constant
slope right episode and and the bound is
a epsilon right but for even for odd you
have read epsilon and the bound is the
root apps on so that's what gives you
the improvement so this is a sort of
math explanation but the high-level
explanation why this why my proof works
is the following so a so you see when
you consider the subproblem it's as if
you're doing a lease decoding but with
sighs with least size l minus 1 right
this size on one less and when l is odd
so how does Plotkin point look like so
for at least size one and two it's here
for this size three and four it's here
so there is this strange periodicity
which only happens in the binary case
and right and so so when you ask me to
prove something for least size of five
right what my proof is effectively
morally reduces to proving something
about this size for right and then we
know that for this size 44 small rate
your your much you have a much better
converse bond right but when you asked
me to prune for l equals 6 i reduced to
l equals 5 and here of course they are
very compared we have very comparable
bounds so roughly speaking that's what a
serious thanks
questions the fact that the maximum is a
teen for j equal to zero that mean that
here you actually added only 10 in the
least 0000 in the previous statements
would be actually true ah hey okay let's
say you mean which side and this thing
it basically means that so we have zero
zeros okay so you see no first so I'm
this has no longer any code words in it
right so this is just a validation of a
function in the averaging did you get
there ok anyways mark lutz yeah let's
think about it later but yeah I remember
I thought about it basically in what you
say that if I have zero a J's here this
is like tau L minus 1 right so it's like
L minus 1 packing all these guys yeah I
remember if there is some connection but
I forgot in what sense no since it is a
long time ago so let's take other
questions offline all right yeah thanks
again